montréal célèbre mais le 375e et coûte
combien
[Musique]
on a calculé le 375e va coûter un
milliard évidemment s'il ya pas de
dépassements de coûts oui un peu plus
d'un milliard de dollars ce c'est à peu
près trois fois le prix du nouvel
amphithéâtre de québec de ce milliard de
dollars ce qui organise les fêtes ont un
budget de 125 millions mais l'essentiel
des dépenses ce sont des infrastructures
comme la place vauquelin ici dans le
vieux-montréal complètement refaite pour
12 millions d'autres exemples le quai où
on accueille les touristes qui
débarquent des bateaux de croisière
revampé pour 78 millions
il ya aussi un ancien dépotoir
transformé en parc 26,6 millions en tout
il ya un peu plus de 40 projets là le
bâtiment derrière ce sera la maison
internationale des arts de la
marionnette pour deux millions cinq cent
sur le milliard de dollars de dépenses
c'est la ville de montréal qui paient la
plus importante part suivi du
gouvernement du québec et celui du
canada
il ya aussi d'autres sources de
financement comme des entreprises
privées
[Musique]
la plupart des legs vont perdurer dans
le temps comme l'illumination du pont
jacques cartier qui est prévu pour dix
ans vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque
chose
écrivez nous
[Musique]